now then David Cameron called the
election result the sweetest victory of
all but let's not forget that he has say
wafer-thin majority which means he's
going to have to listen very very
carefully indeed to all of his back
benches where one of those is the former
government minister Owen Paterson and he
joins me now from Ellesmere in
Shropshire and a very good morning to
you mr. Patterson well as I say he's got
a wafer-thin majority you know that very
well and therefore he has to keep the
party in line one way of doing that as
he decides on the makeup of his
government is he's got a lot more jobs
to hand around than he did when you were
in coalition well good morning first
thing the state is this is a remarkable
victory completely confounded but to the
whole political establishment the
pollsters and the press and it's a real
victory for conservatism offering lower
taxes less regulation getting people
back into work welfare reform
more choice in education health has
really worked and I think what we want
to do is to push on in this government
make sure there is a broad spread across
the ministries it's great that we can
get really vital ministries back like
energy where we frankly got a disastrous
long-term energy policy were led by the
Liberal Democrats well the real problem
the lights might go out it's a really
really great opportunity now to get
common sense conservative ministers in
there and really push on over the next
five years and really consolidate on
this tremendous victory how does he push
on and bring common sense into relations
with Europe that will satisfy people
like you and many others in the
Conservative Party well I think we've
got to give him the time and the space
as I said in the Sunday Times today to
to push ahead with his idea that he can
get what we want through a renegotiation
we have to let him have a real crack at
it
and I was very closely involved in all
the negotiations on c.a.p reform we'd
never have got it through you know that
last night when I speak my best Bavarian
the German offices we work very closely
with the Germans I think it's a real
will on their behalf to come to
agreement there's very broad agreement I
think in Britain that they we voted to
join a market all this rubbish the EU
and the three million jobs it's the
market that delivers
when I suspect too many more than three
million jobs as five million jobs in
Europe depend on trade with us it's the
trade we want and they're going to have
to leave us and set up a new country in
order to fix the horrors of the eurozone
in order they can transfer funds legally
between the wealth creating areas like
southern germany southern Holland down
to the difficult areas southern Spain in
Italy so they're going to leave us an
effectively form a new country we have a
great opportunity to have a completely
new arrangement based around the market
we can withdraw from the political and
new judicial arrangements well we got to
give the Prime Minister time he's got to
set out his vision I mean I have a
tremendously optimistic vision of where
we could be regaining our role on those
really important international bodies
that album decide regulation but the
point they do have a fair crack and give
your time well that's the point though
isn't it Mr Paterson if his vision
doesn't coincide with your vision and
others vision and death he can't do it
in the time available we he's got to
hold that referendum before the the end
of 2017 and you know a lot of parallels
been drawn with 1992 from the point of
view of your party the surprise election
victory but of course we know what then
happened to John Major is his so-called
awkward squad over Europe in the end
tour the party apart well I know this is
the press narrative you're all hoping is
going to happen I think we wish the
Prime Minister well don't forget our
European the 27 partners will have seen
this they'll have seen a very very
resounding statement by the British
people to back the prime minister's
program he go he goes there with a real
mandate and I think we've got to give
him the time and space deliver there's
very broad agreement across the Tory
Party and as we've seen there is broad
agreement with the small sea
conservatives who've been completely
ignored by the metropolitan media in the
pollsters and spoke up they have very
broad agreement for moving towards a
range Minh Thuy enjoy the benefits of
the single market but we're not bossed
around by the political and judicial
arrangements every day in Defra when I
was doing it I had to make judgments as
to how far we could push a decision in
case we got infringement sand
infractions and ultimately fines from
the European Union we are going to be
the just overtaking France with the
fifth biggest economy in the world we
can run our own show and we can get back
on those World bodies and really
three galvanized well free trade because
the lack of free trade and the fact that
stalled is causing these horrendous
problems in very unstable parts of the
world like southern at middle and
southern northern Africa so I see a
really positive role for us and we've
got to give the Prime Minister with his
massive mandate the very best shots to
deliver are you available to make these
arguments back in government if you were
asked I think ago that is entirely down
to the Prime Minister who's making his
choices as we speak but I've been
reelected here with an increased
majority to like to say this part of the
world is all blue for the first time
since 1970 and I'll be playing my full
role representing small see
conservatives and their views in the new
Parliament but willing to serve if
required obviously yes I mean everyone
everyone would we what we want this
government to succeed last we've got rid
of the ball and chain of the Lib Dems we
can crack on with a really positive
common-sense program so we need to
deliver the boundary changes we've been
held back by this nonsense that John
Major got 14 point 1 billion votes and
majority 21 Tony Blair got 13 and a half
and God majora ham 79 we've got it even
that out we've got to resolve the issues
of English votes for English laws and
we've got it obviously worked closely
with the Scots make them feel welcome in
the Union and my belief is on the
Scottish issue they should be
responsible for raising the money that
they spend and suddenly you change the
dynamic we've got a great leader the
Scot of the Scottish Conservative Party
suddenly you have competition in
Scotland between parties to deliver
lower taxes and better service so I mean
we're hearing from Chris Grayling who's
going to be we understand looking after
those there's issues concerning Scotland
that Scotland should have the strongest
devolved powers of any on earth
how far can that go well I just
referring back to my previous comments
the moment I knew all along that this
devolution settlements taupey lopsided
and asymmetrical and behind me that view
behind you is Wales there are decisions
made on health in Wales by a bad Labour
government in Cardiff
up here affecting me in awe structure
and I can do nothing about it we always
knew this is a symmetrical and what's
happened is the Scottish referendum has
woken the English up to that and the
Scots cannot treat England or some piggy
bank which can be raided
so that excessive amounts of money are
taken from England without
responsibility and the Scots can run
around promising free health care free
there's free holidays in Lanzarote and
expect the English to pay there has to
be a resolution so English matters have
to be side by English MPs and the fair
thing is to give the Scots real
responsibility I would be happy to see
them raising the money that they spend
and then you reestablish that link
between how you vote you'd think really
carefully in Scotland are you going to
vote for effectively Marxist SNP or
would you vote for a prudent Scottish
Conservative Party offering lower taxes
and better service and suddenly you
change the whole dynamic of politics of
Scotland within the UK
okay mr. Patterson good to talk to you
thank you very much indeed for joining
us at on Paterson there in Ellesmere in
Shropshire now